hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay I'm back
with this douchebag and I am NOT gonna
mess around I'm gonna shotgun him in his
face so I'm ready for you buddy oh my
god can you not die or something I'll be
back in a bit
oh yeah apparently I just was a runaway
so I thought I'll do I'll be back in a
minute
hello everybody I'm back again here
again Oh wonder what's gonna happen
f
hide right behind me oh no I'm almost
out of run juice right you bastard so
kind of creepy I didn't get the gun but
can't just be gone is he
wait a minute oh wow No dumpy-dumpy
ah I probably should tried to get the
gun but I was oh I was tired of doing
that I just wanted to move forward I
don't even need a gun I'm so tough
anyway moving on bike
gimme don't need this right now you can
probably use it buddy
oh hello cuz there seems to be some
diabolical occurrences in this
neighborhood I'll go back there later
nope I'll go back there right now
alright and he's gonna jump up at me oh
no no don't you miss me at all nothing
can stand up to mob a town nothing no
nothing ha ha you didn't even get to
blow up your head alright
I'm Hollis it's safe
[Music]
oh no it's they need permits all over
again
oh no I thought was it oh no what now
why am I getting crappy frame rates
nothing goes right alright hopefully
it'll ah lady take a chill pill there we
go were you lagging my computer okay oh
wow how does it even work
bono busting through huh yo whoa whoa
whoa whoa I heard your creepy crawly
know what I've noticed about this baton
is it's a lot slower hit and jump at the
same time and I want to see you fat ugly
doors
oh yeah it is where am i go
wait what done wait what what bad
[Applause]
I can I get like a spear or something
shove them for the distance
[Music]
Matan why don't I just flip the baton
the other way or hold it like a stick
just give me a short range all right
that was a good secret that I found glad
I went there who's in here huh huh hello
anybody pistol another baton just in
case you missed the first one okay that
means it probably gonna give me the gun
again okay you got me you got me good oh
[Music]
okay
that was a good one haha okay all right
where am I why am I going down here I
don't even know what my objective is
right now honestly
hi hi buddy what oh yeah you don't want
to even take a step closer oh you took
us across that line I dare you Oh what
another one no no no you can't even look
at me right
God do I do anything else not pro the
ton is so slow when it comes to those
guys where did I go
what was the point of that
oh okay all right yeah this does a good
way to go stairs are out take these
precarious living legends
logging my way where did all this come
from good question I didn't think about
that but there's a bathtub why why Oh No
huh okay hello
monsters I'm telling me I need a bigger
gun just tells me hello please hold this
Oh
want some what I'm totally surprised
that I'm making any progress because I'm
just guessing randomly wars without any
idea as to where I'm going
something tells me don't go in the water
hey that's terrible experiences with
water they're way too peaceful
[Music]
what press it I dare you
[Music]
gotta find out what it does huh what
that do oh okay okay move that over okay
this is no wait
press it press that that just gets me
out of it but anywhere would okay all
right that did okay then move that one
there that one did nothing nothing that
moved it back okay so maybe I need a
right order
I'll move it to the right location or
maybe I don't know what I'm doing and I
should move on and it'll probably send
me back here if I need to solve this
puzzle maybe some big Easter egg Oh safe
finally oh my god it's been forever
since I had a save point my goodness
gracious
Oh jiminy Christmas
[Music]
welcome to Gustav Donald Park silently
she flew quiet as a whisper in the dark
she came upon a river and headed south
the king of all the birds flew higher
than the owl gloating as he went four
legged carnivore sneaked side by side to
his prey ready to strike whenever a
movement was made the equestrian bees
didn't want her sleep to come so if she
fled to the west uncommon ok this is
telling me where they need to go ok
something goes south the horse goes west
bird flew higher the carnivores sneaked
side by side them to his prey
so Prai followed the movement of its
prey I'm guessing
[Music]
okay I'm gonna ponder this puzzle and in
the meantime after I cut in here so
thank you guys so much for watching and
I will see you in the next part bye bye
[Music]